un quartier entier de paris au bord de
la crise de nerfs chaque mois de
ramadhan depuis 2009
rachid et son équipe viennent en aide
aux plus démunis 18e arrondissement de
paris
vous avez chérif le patron envie rahmane
omar trois cuisiniers une dizaine de
bénévoles pour l'une des plus grande
soupe populaire de paris c'est ici que
tout a surpris car pour des raisons
techniques des grosses marmites comme ça
ça ne peut pas sauver cuisiner sur des
cases mais ils gagnèrent classique ou du
professionnel vous avez la france et
quand lille dessous 50% de financement
privé des dons en nature de la vie st
bernard un soutien conséquent de la
grande mosquée de paris et de la ville
c'est la recette du succès pour une
association qui alerte en criant haut et
fort que la maison brioni aller voir
tout à l'heure ça va me rappeler après
la guerre de 39 40
quand les gens étaient rationnés avec un
ticket par contre on est là où ça a été
un désastre économique sanitaire et
social dans le quartier en tout cas lors
des émeutes d arafat pour la boucle et
bien vous allez me répondre à ses
besoins
parce qu'il ya une vraie misère qu'ils
sont frais aujourd'hui il est 15 heures
rue des poissonniers
c'est sur ce terrain vague au coeur du
quartier de la goutte d'or que va avoir
lieu la distribution
une armée de bénévoles s'activent sa
mission confectionnés tout de 405
qu'est ce qu'il y a dans les salles
ça dépend des dons mais en général il ya
du lait du pain de la confiture des
fruits des dates
il est 16h30 la file d'attenté temps
déjà sur plus de 300 mètres presque un
pâté de maison entier une fille sage
disciplinés mais que la pandémie a
plongé dans la misère et du désespoir
je suis pas surpris outre mesure de
l'ampleur de la fréquentation
il ya plein de gens qui ont perdu leur
travail il ya plein de jean-marie
marginaux qui vivaient de mendicité ou
de la fin autant perdu aussi leur
manière de gagner entre guillemets leur
vie il ya tous les anciens de la goutte
d'or qui dans les hôtels meublés
très précarisés 17 heures lassus arrive
enfin marquant le début de la
distribution de nourriture
une foule chaque jour plus nombreuse et
a toujours la série 600 personnes alors
imaginez s'il n'ya pas confinement et
les gens puissent se dépasser on aura
donné 700 de la pauvreté mais aussi de
la détresse parfois du désespoir
il n'est pas rare que certains craquent
ils veulent raconter leur histoire
le drame qu'ils vivent au quotidien à
l'exemple de cette femme arrivée en gt
17e mélodies bolena j'essaie de les
zapper
ça ne bouge pas vous êtes combien madame
fermer son sera fini de cette soupe
populaire providentiel si rien n'est
fait par les pouvoirs publics
ses organisateurs craignent des émeutes
de la faim